one week ago tonight an unarmed black
man named George Floyd was killed by a
Minneapolis police officer every day
since people all over the world have
gathered to demand change and call
attention to horrific racial and
Justices affecting communities of color
every day joining me tonight is Van
Jones CNN political commentator and the
CEO of reform Alliance thank you very
much for being with us I said up front
that I don't want to do much talking
tonight I'd rather you did the talking
so why don't we start what are you
feeling right now how are you you know I
am I was as sad as I've ever been I
think from a black perspective as a
parent we we had this one little hope
this little tiny thread that there was
something we could tell our children
that they could do that would keep them
safe from even the worst officers if
they didn't run they didn't talk back
they didn't have drugs on it they didn't
drive away if they kept their hands on
their understand what they said yes sir
no no ma'am that you know they we've got
to sprinkle this little fairy dust on
our kids every day about how to survive
you know encounters with the police in
this situation there's nothing we could
have told our kids to survive it was a
lynching from our point of view I mean
just literally in broad daylight
this guy just you know one minute two
minute three minutes four minutes five
minutes six minutes seven minutes with
people begging for this guy's life and
that's that brings back such historical
trauma for us because that used to
happen a lot just at the lynching of
black men in public with the community
being helpless and and lynchings were
designed to humiliate and intimidate the
commune the whole community we can do
whatever we want to you and you can't do
anything about it
and when one's law enforcement doing it
you really feel helpless so that's why I
think you see this incredible despair in
the black community
um and I think that's why you've seen
this out output at the same time through
our tears we I think might start to
notice that the fear that nobody cares
about us all the way people you know
don't understand may not be as
well-founded as we think because there's
20 30 40 50 million white people who saw
that video who are all so shocked and
horrified and are now saying hey I might
be late to the party here but what what
can I do now that is the positive you
know out of a breakdown you can't have a
breakthrough and there is a positive
side of this that nobody's defending I
mean you're not seeing you know people
may argue about the disturbances which
we can talk about but nobody is
defending what this officer did and it
does create a some small bit of hope
that's starting to rise up in me that we
could have at least a better
conversation listen you're never gonna
get rid of police brutality just because
you'll never get rid of bad schools or
bad restaurants I mean you're always
gonna have human being to just do bad
stuff but you can create an environment
where when it happens the response is
it's effective enough that you know
other people don't want to go down that
same bad road you can't close down you
know restaurants that are you know not
meeting the sanitation requirement you
can you can fire a teacher you don't you
can do certain things so yeah I'm never
you're never gonna get rid of racism
never gonna get rid of police brutality
but you can have a better system so that
you don't have lawlessness in law
enforcement then leading to lawlessness
on the street that we can do it feels to
me and and again I want you know I want
to hear how you're feeling that there's
an anger and there's also a sense right
now people are feeling very fragile
there there's almost a
a state of people of really being on the
edge and it's a mixture of feelings it's
not just anger it's it's also I mean
obviously there's a lot of anger out
there and justifiably so but it's more
than that it's a little more complex
than that because this is not a new
story this is not the first time it's
happened and in my lifetime I mean I'm
just a couple of years old when the
first big riots hit after dr. Martin
Luther King is shot there's a feeling
that we've been here again and again and
again and again does this one feel
different to you in for some reason I
think it feels different because there's
literally no excuse like you know all
these other ones oh well he was running
well he was this well he was talking
back or he punched the person who store
he was an axe murderer or whatever it
was I mean this person a $20 counterfeit
you know kill a guy over a counterfeit
$20 bill that maybe wasn't even his and
it's in broad daylight and everything
that we said well let's get body cams
they had body cams well let's you know
make sure community young people pay
attention you know bring out the cell
phones all that was done and the guy
just sat there with his hands in his
pocket so while he was killing some
white so I think I think that the the
nature of it is is is so much more
shocking it's so much more more visible
and there's no excuse you can't point to
a single thing after listen even after a
minute to it was justified after minute
4 5 6 7 8 it wasn't so so you're now in
that world and so and then I think the
other other thing is that the when the
local prosecutor came forward and
charged only one of the officers with
third-degree murder he's like the most
horrific crime of the century record it
to the whole world and you get third
degree murder I've never heard an
attorney I've never heard of 3rd degree
murder yeah can you can you do me a
favor and I know that this is something
that you've you've studied you are an
attorney I didn't understand 3rd degree
murder and my 14 year old son asked me
last night what's third degree murder
and I was embarrassed that I couldn't I
didn't
and I didn't know how that was even
applicable it didn't make sense to me
yeah at the third degree murder is like
a oopsie murder
it's like oops be like if you were just
if you were driving past a house he
thought was empty and fired your weapon
and oops there was somebody in there
like like the intention was completely
innocent but you were maybe being
reckless that's what that is now here's
a problem with it
prosecutors don't behave this way with
everybody else especially with black
people
with everybody else you'll get 27
charges and everybody standing around
will also get arrested and get at least
15 charges so you have maximum number of
people you know arrested because the
standard for arrest is probable cause
and you can arrest people for
practically nothing so everybody gets
arrested and everybody gets charged with
a thousand things and then you plead
down from there when this local
prosecutor gives us creampuff charge
that nobody's ever heard of and that's
it and doesn't arrest anyone else wasn't
gonna plead down to a traffic ticket I
mean use your Stetson you're starting
with third degree murder that's when the
protests because everybody in the black
media uh-uh this is the fix is in and
that's when it got worse not better
because of the charges because it did
feel there was also this lag time
everyone saw that horrible video it's
completely inexplicable and there was
this lag time that before anything was
announced anything was done and you
wonder might things be different now how
if immediately people had come forward
and said no this was wrong and here are
the steps we're gonna take an immediate
and you know immediate investigation and
these are you know these people are
being placed under arrest
look I think that you'd still have
protests for a short it's just so
shocking
you have protests but it was been a
different kind and you wouldn't have had
the level of exasperation and
frustration I mean you still have the
three other officers not charged the
reason you charge everybody is because
you get people to turn on each other
you know you and probable
cause is such a low standard you can
literally arrest and charge everybody
and then you figure it out you have
leverage to figure it out the idea they
don't even want leverage they don't even
want leverage I mean it's it's a
complete double standard and that's
again so then it's salt in the wound
like nobody would be treated this way if
a white one and we're being treated this
way by anybody it would be I mean the
entire block would have come out and
just tackle the guy I mean and so and
then and then the prosecutor is behaving
differently as well there is a way out
of this you know I think a lot of people
just feel total despair I don't think
that that's where we should stay I don't
think we should deny the pain but we
shouldn't let the pain have the last
word there have been you know you know
they've been lynchings in the past there
have been bad cops in the past and we've
come through that as a black community
as an American community and there's an
opportunity here first of all justice in
this case means all the cops get charged
there's no way that you know sitting
around basically an accessory to murder
you should get away scot-free
something needs to happen number two
there can be now common ground on this
question of lawlessness in law
enforcement there could be a bipartisan
bill in Congress that would do some
smart stuff like for instance you know
one reason you know police officers act
the way that they do you can't sue them
individually so they have little total
total immunity so no matter what happens
maybe they get demoted or fire they
still keep their house they still keep
their their boat they still keep the
truck so there's a way that that needs
to be addressed if you do something
egregious you should also be able to
have your personal a fortune at stake
that could be a break you want to create
checks and balances and brakes on from a
law enforcement family my father was a
cop in the military my uncle just
retired from Memphis City police force I
understand you know cops aren't Satan
they're not superheroes
they're just city employees some are
good some suck you got to have systems
to kill with the ones that suck and if
you just say because somebody has
on a blue uniform I'm gonna back up no
matter what that's not constitutional
democracy that's gang mentality because
of what you're wearing I'm on your side
that's gang mentality
we're not the reason that Democratic
Republic trust a small group of armed
men and non women with a monopoly on
violence why because there's checks
there's balances there's process there's
laws so we entrust you with the monopoly
on violence in a system once you step
out of that system and you start abusing
that if the system doesn't pull you back
now you just got lawlessness of the
worst kind you have essentially a number
of gangs in the community one of them
just happens to have on a badge that's
not what you want but that's what you've
got in way too many neighborhoods and
way too many cities and right and left
should disagree with that reality right
and left you come together and say let's
fix that let's put some more tools in
place put some more checks and balances
in place so you can have the police
obeying the law and therefore the
citizenry obeying the law and that's how
you have peaceful streets and nobody
wants peaceful streets more nobody wants
peaceful streets more than
african-americans we're not a part of
some pro riot Lobby or some pro crime
Lobby I'm raising two black boys here in
Los Angeles I do not want riots here
I just want lawful policing and peaceful
streets just like everybody else yeah
there's a I don't know how you react to
this this seems to happen whenever
there's a an incident like this and
sadly there are way too many of them you
have people in the white community
saying and.and I'm gonna say the white
liberal community saying I didn't
realize I didn't quite realize the
extent and it feels a little bit like
fired on that you know that that the the
time for people to be saying I didn't
realize well I didn't quite understand
how bad it was I'm catching up now that
we have passed that point quite a while
ago and that it's there there is no
excuse
listen I I feel that way now I do
there's a fatigue this is just a fatigue
you know why do you pay money to go to
college why do you pay tuition because
educating somebody is costly okay it's
costly if I have to sit here and educate
every one of my white friends every time
something happens I have to educate one
of my white friends every Facebook post
or my high school buddy every
well-intentioned colleague it is costly
and they not pay me no tuition this is
just a pure cost and at a certain point
you're like can you do your own homework
can you can you can you just watch the
thirteenth documentary can you just read
the new Jim Crow just just just do a
little bit so I don't have to do all of
it myself every day and usually I'm
surrounded and outnumbered if you're a
professional black person or class black
person right they were only twelve
percent of the country most of time
you're surrounded outnumbered and you
gotta have to now try to one more time
create a free college for somebody else
that you know you don't benefit from you
be actually a drain but it's tough and
you know James Baldwin said it the best
he said when it comes to issues of race
white people are always innocent
they're always innocent and their
innocence constitutes their crime how
can you be innocent this link you but I
mean quit being innocent this innocence
Act is it now criminal but he just admit
we live in a country with a terrible
history nobody likes that reality is
uncomfortable but you the fact you can't
run away from it 364 days out of the
year doesn't mean you should because it
just it's just a part of being in a
democratic multiracial multicultural
multi-faith democracy we have to work to
learn about each other and if you're in
the majority the whole country conspires
to make sure you know your own history
they call that American history you have
to do a little bit more work to learn to
Latino history a little bit more work to
learn the black history a little bit
more work
eskimo history whatever you want to call
it that but that's that's the price of
being a good citizen in a multiracial
democracy and we're one of the few in
the history of the world it takes work
and all that work shouldn't just fall on
my shoulders to do the education the I
think there was a and I think you've
recently quoted it but it was a
interesting quote I think from Malcolm X
that he was I and and you'll correct me
you probably know it better than I do
but I think he said he was sometimes
more afraid of a liberal you know
someone who was well intentioned but
ignorant than he was of an outright
bigot and felt that in a way that could
be more insidious is is do you feel that
that's something that we might be
experiencing right now yeah you know I
got in a lot of trouble early in the
week pointing it out but you know we're
all friends here at some point we have
to speak honestly with each other and
there is a way and Malcolm talked about
the southern wolf versus the northern
fox
he said that southern wolf yeah he bares
his teeth batcher and you know he's mad
at you you know he doesn't want you
around he said that that that northern
fox you know he see you might be smiling
you know you didn't looks a little bit
more friendly but it's still you know
you're still in real danger and so I do
think we have to look at the fact that a
lot of people who vote for Democrats who
support causes who share all the right
stuff on their Instagram page and all
that sort of stuff you know to be honest
don't have a lot of personal black
friends don't have a lot of personal
skin in the game don't hire a lot of
African Americans don't have African
American lawyers or accountants or
dentist or you know places where the
black community does have a lot of
professionals stacked up they don't
avail themselves of those services they
will call the cops just like that woman
at Central Park you know in an instant
and you know and act just like I mean
the Ku Klux Klan wouldn't have acted any
better or any worse than that white
woman in Central Park calling the police
on that on that black man for no reason
and the bird watch there's a bird
watcher
Millie scared of a bird watch you know
in the park so so these are the kinds of
things there's a real opportunity
because if you gotta be honest and this
is a this is the worst part the worst
thing I'll say it safe tonight if you
got to be honest there is a way in which
white people choking off opportunity
choking off dignity choking off their
ability to thrive and rise and looking
like they're not doing anything wrong
and blaming the black people that's kind
of America's thing that's a little bit
of our thing and when you look in the
face of that guy he looked like he
wasn't doing anything wrong yes he
answered his pocket he's literally
killing somebody and if you ask him why
you say because this guy's a threat well
hold on a second you have to have a very
particular worldview to look at this
picture and think the guy down there is
a threat in the year though that the
innocent hero and yet that we can't do
that don't we board room after board
room just hiring decision after hiring
decision Bank decision after Bank
decision somehow always the same group
gets choked out and the other group
benefits and they're innocent and so
these are the kinds of things that I
would encourage people to think about is
there some way that I'm like that guy
you know my kind of like that cop would
I overreact am I afraid am i giving
enough oxygen to the black people in my
community do I have enough but the
awareness of the pain do I have enough
awareness of the suffering or am I
looking away when everybody else in the
world can see man that community
suffering in your country yeah I think
what you're pointing out and which makes
a lot of sense to me is it's very easy
for people to watch that footage that
horrible footage demonize those officers
say that's terrible I feel so terrible
for you people and I am on your side and
it can all feel like an empty exercise
it can all feel
and meaningless as opposed to how did we
get to that point right what can we do
I'm curious I I try to avoid the Trump
of things not not for any other reason
that it can be such a big distraction
and I I consider it a victory when I
have long conversations with people
where he has not discussed or he does
not monopolize the conversation
what could a president do now today that
would be meaningful let's let's forget
for a moment that which president it is
what could a president do today that
would be meaningful and be a salve to
the african-american community make them
feel better and make them feel like they
were heard what would what would it take
well you know ironically some of the
things that Trump is actually doing
ironically you know have the Department
of Justice and the FBI get in there and
figure out what the heck is going on
that has done has been done in his being
nut you know receive a briefing directly
in the Oval Office about it and then
speak out publicly which he also did the
situation that we're in is it's the
things that he should stop doing that
caused problems the tweeting and this
sort of stuff but there you know I'm
trying to be fair with everybody there
have been things that that the truck
ministration has done that are
appropriate you should stop doing
certain things and then beyond what has
been done you know we need to get
together we need to come together if we
don't come together we're gonna end up
where we're headed where we're headed
it's not good you know you could have
and what about one more of these
videotapes away from heaven you know
five six American cities burned to the
ground
I mean we're this is not a good
trajectory to be on as a country and
nobody would like that outcome so you
have an outcome that's looming that
nobody wants you can get everybody
together
man would it be great for everybody to
go to the White House everybody
n-double-a-cp the NRA I mean everybody
just go to the White House and just sit
down and just cry and just have some
ministers come and pray over your body
and and secular people you'll have some
musicians musicians come and just have a
big cry and then listen to law
enforcement say how they don't like
what's going on and they're willing to
make some changes because obviously you
know something's going on that they
don't want and listen to some of those
young kids talk about how let me also
kids are so heartbreaking I just want to
be able to go into a white neighborhood
and not feel afraid I mean simple things
and just just get together that's what I
would like mm-hmm just get together this
is this you know we you know when the
funeral happens I mean wouldn't it be
amazing if the if all the Republican
leaders nah Democrat leaders we're
sitting in there I mean I guess we got
social distance or whatever but you know
if whatever it is if this is a time to
say listen I can score points and you
can score points I can call you a racist
you can call me a socialist I can say
you're an Tifa you can say I would not I
mean we can do this we've been doing
this now for years but this one you've
got to draw a circle around and
Americans are drawn a circle around I
mean you know the disturbances that's
different but this in this particular
murder Americans have drawn a circle
around there there is room now I think
for a president to bring everybody
together I want to make sure I mention
reform Alliance this is something the
CEO of reform Alliance and talk about
taking action to move the puzzle piece a
little forward tell us what it is well
you know jay-z and meek Mill and Robert
Smith and Robert Kraft and a bunch of
billionaires including Clara loose eye
and Novogratz and Dan Loeb
Laura Arnold all got together a year and
a half ago and said to me people are
going to jail for petty stuff and too
many people are caught up on probation
and parole for too long and they're
going back to jail for petty stuff let's
do something to try to have fewer people
going to jail for petty stuff and
because you shouldn't deprive people of
their liberty lightly and then between
the köppen thing which has now made the
jails full of this plague and people are
dying in the prisons and huge numbers
and then this you know incident you we
realize we're also we're not just trying
to protect liberty we're trying to
protect people's lives and we partnered
with Jack Dorsey from Twitter to get
masks into all the jails and prisons we
have legislation moving in a number of
states to try to reduce the number of
people going to jail for probation and
parole violations online crime technical
violation a lot of things like that but
this thing set us on our butt and jay-z
himself picked up the phone and called
the governor of Minnesota and asked him
personally to make sure that the case
was given to the state attorney general
alabs to be african-american there's
also just a fair-minded prosecutor on so
that it wouldn't we wouldn't keep going
down this road of having the local
prosecutor screw up the case and then
people burned down the country and
thankfully for that reason and many
others the governor did give the case to
a better prosecutor so we have a better
chance of justice I think you have a
better chance of a bipartisan bill that
could really fix law enforcement some
important ways and there also needs to
be a better chance of to put some money
into these communities you know all
these corporations and banks should get
together let's help these communities
well we see what's going on if you if
you have justice legislation and
Economic Opportunity we can come out of
the stronger and better and that's I'm
starting to feel some hope now for that
I'm starting to feel some help you know
we we didn't really even get much of a
chance to talk before we hooked up on
zoom' today and so I wasn't sure what
your state of mind was going to be and
again I wanted you to do the talking and
I'm hearing I'm hearing anguish and
frustration but I'm also hearing some
hope that there might be an opportunity
here as and I want to be careful when I
say that and I'm saying there's an
opportunity in a horrible situation but
there might be an opportunity here to to
move ahead to move up and to get and to
be a little better
aye aye I think so I think if people
don't stop at pity because pity burns
out it doesn't feel good if we move to
opportunity to be moved to saying hey
listen who knows I mean that guy that
got killed and he might have cured
cancer for all we know that guy was what
his kids could have become or whatever
so we wasting some genius we're missing
out on some possible best friends who
ever had it's possible great employees
or employers or contractors or or
neighbors what can I do in my personal
life people go lately how can I fix the
police department trust me that's not
easy
but your own workplace you might be able
to get an internship program in place
you might be able to mentor somebody um
don't forget how much you know not from
a book how much you know because
somebody sat down and talked to you one
of the problems when you're black is
it's hard to find a person will talk to
you honestly you know the conversation
gets stiff or tense or whatever and or
it's just it just doesn't happen because
you're not even you don't even know that
that building you're driving past is a
lodge or a Country Club it's just a
building you've never been invited in
there and so you know is are there
people you can mentor that people who
and the thing about mentorship is you
always get more out of it than you give
anyway
it's not charity you wind up so much
smarter and so much more interesting you
know oh I'm talking about my kid from
the other side of town and now you're
the most interesting person at
Thanksgiving you know so you always get
more than you can you give but those are
things that I would ask people do we'd
have to change some laws but I'll tell
you what if we start changing who's in
our phone book who who's in our cell
phone who do we texting with every
couple of days who we that's that's
really where the change has got to start
happening because then
you know suddenly you know somebody says
something in the conversation a second
that's not funny you know I know a guy
who's black and and and I've learned the
hard way that's that that can wind up
killing somebody and know if you wet
what we didn't know that you were
feeling that way well I do feel that way
now
and suddenly you start wiping this stuff
out at the social level long before it
ever gets to the legal level and I think
that's important
well I I cannot thank you enough for
doing this today this it I've always
loved talking to you in the past we've
had really good conversations and I I
did not want to hear my voice today I
was really happy that it could be your
voice so they listen you won't you've
always been good to me yeah I'm telling
that I show launch or a book you've
always had me on and you know I'm glad I
created friendship between us and now we
can use it to try to bring a little bit
of hope to people and I'll come back any
time you have it sir thank you so much
this was very meaningful to me and I
stay well and and and good luck with
your kids and handling all of this and
let's keep the conversation going
will do thank you very much thank you
sir